[Applause]
[Music]
hey sports ball fans it's a great week
for your team to carry the thing to the
other thing before the other team can
can stop them with a different thing and
for the rest of us it's time to wrap
died and solve puzzles actually sports
you're sounding pretty good right about
now but hey don't forget to subscribe to
get all the game releases delivered
right to you you've probably seen those
horrifying player face oh oh oh that is
oh that's nasty but don't let that stop
you MLB the show is still the best way
to get your baseball fix with 17 you can
take a swing in the new retro mode which
plays and sounds like the 16-bit ball
games you remember dynasty mode has also
been buffed up with more missions
rewards and live content that changes
based on real-world baseball news Road
to the show has also been expanded to go
beyond stadiums and if you want to
control a whole franchise you've got new
options for managing your team and staff
MLB the show 17 steps onto the field on
Tuesday March 28 only on ps4 speaking of
PlayStation franchises everyone's
favorite rapping dog is coming back not
including Snoop Dogg of course Parappa
the rapper remastered looks and sounds
better than its 20-year old counterpart
thanks to a new 1080p look or 4k if
you're running on the ps4 pro and
enhanced audio this time around you'll
also be able to see and feel the beat in
other words you can enlarge the icons to
help with your timing or use the dual
shocks rumble feature to stay in the
rhythm the beat drops on March 28 but
only on ps4 I hope you're ready to chop
onions and get your driver's license
again
[Music]
and now it's time to move from rap music
straight to violence swear I'm not a
cliche but we are going to talk about
Dark Souls 3 the ring city is the final
expansion for the game and also the end
of the franchise for the foreseeable
future that's pretty appropriate since
this DLC takes your player to the edge
of the world where all the kingdoms and
timelines begin crashing into each other
spoiler alert that's not really a
spoiler that's a pretty big deal for the
Dark Souls lore you can expect the usual
new weapons armor and bosses on all
platforms on March 28 and you can watch
us fight one of those bosses the demon
Prince right now just be prepared for a
lot of this
[Music]
hey who wants a new Nintendo switch game
and if you haven't made the switch
yourself don't worry has been heroes is
also making its way onto ps4 xbox one
and pc this is the tale of a bunch of
adventurers including rogues axe
fighters and Mexican wrestlers and it
plays out like an RPG roguelike hybrid
your ragtag group can learn bigger and
better spells and you can combine them
for even more powerful attacks to take
down the evil great ghoul on the 28th
just be prepared for a lot of this
[Music]
did those creepy MLB faces get to you
well hopefully you're not afraid of
clowns because um because thimble we'd
Park stars1 named ransom a dead guy
named Franklin and two detectives now
that sounds like the setup for a bar
joke but it's also how this point and
click adventure kicks off if you
couldn't tell just by looking at it
thimble weed part comes from some of the
guys behind classics like maniac mansion
and Monkey Island so be ready to combine
all sorts of goofy items to solve
puzzles you can start investigating on
ps4 xbox one pc ios and android on march
30th and those are the biggest games
will be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with more games next week
[Music]